for some reason i really want to have a
threesome
look at elena's face oh god
little did i know steven was gonna be
the most interesting part of this
tell-all and you know that is never a
good thing
nine girls were sending me inappropriate
messages and images of like you know
their boobs and naked pictures he had
all these revelations including
admitting to talking to nine different
women since he's been married to alina
and then i
foolishly started sending pictures of
myself and things like that but it
doesn't stop there
steven's ex joined the tell-all and made
an emotional plea to
but i don't think he's going to change
if anything i would say he's gotten
worse
we're going to talk about it plus what
about the fight tell you about binium
tells ari's ex-husband leandro to back
off but he's not budging what she has to
tell me
she she is her own individual and she
needs to make that decision
hey a naughty day fans fam it's melicia
before we get into the messiest parts of
the tell-all quick mention
jenny and submit did not tell his
parents they got married as expected and
come to find out his mom and dad are
back to their old ways of treating jenny
like an outsider all it took was two or
three months to pass and everything was
forgotten sean gave submit two
opportunities to reveal their big secret
is there anything else you want to say
to your parents but he didn't take it he
said he'd rather tell them face to face
and i respect that because we don't know
how his mom would have reacted
on national tv how nervous
were you to tell them i spoke to jenny
and submit ahead of the tell-all about
married life and he admitted in that
moment he was terrified on the scale as
we said a scale of 1 to 10 hours
yeah he was 100 100 was
very much now well you know who else was
on a hundred
stephen
let's talk about it he came into the
building on fire with a little too much
to say don't tell king i said it i think
he looks a little bit older in person
than he does on the tv he shaded kenny
backstage instead don't tell as if this
is not a tv show evelyn i think this is
the most modest i've ever seen you
dressed oh my god once they sat down he
randomly called out evelyn for her
turtleneck whoa
stephen
it's not no it's just a fact and yeah
while he was just being honest it was
unnecessary
i've already got a list
plus on top of all that he revealed he
prepared a list
to roast the cast members who come for
him this was all before the actual
tell-all even started hello and welcome
to 90 day fiance the other way the
couple's tell all okay fast forward to
when it was stephen and elena's turn in
the hot seat steven did not shy away
from his behavior this season i
definitely feel like i'm the worst
person in this room except for maybe
corey
technically i'm not in the room okay
but
when you think that he's gone the
farthest that he's gonna go
or said the wildest thing he's gonna say
child it gets worse
stephen have you been talking to other
women
uh
steven reluctantly revealed that he's
been talking to other women while being
married to alina yes i have been
okay so that's the deal
i've been talking
everyone laughed but i don't see
anything funny he has a whole wife and
he's playing with her heart steven went
into detail and confessed that just the
other week after he and elena got into a
fight he started responding to different
women online who reached out to him
probably about
nine girls were sending me inappropriate
messages and images of like you know
their boobs and naked pictures
i started responding back you know kind
of
encouraging that and then i
foolishly started sending pictures of
myself and things like that
you know
wow
that was even too much for victor wow
who has dibbled and dabbled in some
cheating i mean
who will never cheat you
apparently it's a thing for 90 day cast
members to receive random nudes
i even got boobs sent to me kenny said
he got one from a woman i don't know
what she was trying to do she should
know he is not interested
i just sticking my tongue out but when
it comes to steven he fell for it and
although he claims he didn't send nude
pictures back he still chose to do
something inappropriate and i was saying
like wow i have a really long tongue
it's too bad i don't know how to use it
yes
he also admitted to telling the women
they're hot
this guy is too much
during steven's confession elena kept
her composure and i know that this is
the tell-all but
if i was in her position i would have
told him to close his mouth i've already
chosen to stay with you
[Music]
personally i would have felt embarrassed
you're having me out here looking
foolish
just zip it they don't have to know all
that alina did you know that
yeah
because
those girls they
they sent me all the screenshots in and
yes
interestingly enough some of the women
set steven up
all right if you thought all of that was
a lot
you haven't heard anything yet just take
a listen to steven's excuse for his
actions
also i feel like i have a lot of sexual
energy so like there's a lot of
repression going on within myself
it would be
easier if we were able to find a way
where i wouldn't have to repress
these urges and these feelings as much
and then he took it up another notch i
really want to have a threesome
and oh god
oh my god
worth too much too i had told elena
about this
nearly since the beginning
that it's something i wanted to try
uh-uh okay let's get real what rubs me
the wrong way is if that is such a huge
desire of his and alina is not down for
it or she doesn't understand it i was
like very lost and confused and i don't
i don't know why so her dream and move
forward with this marriage what it
sounds like is he's trying to ease his
way into having a number of wives
is he one of the mormons to find like
seven different ways and another thing
it comes off as if stephen uses honesty
as a means to manipulate
he can cross all these boundaries in his
relationship but as long as he's honest
and confesses
he should be forgiven and viewed as
sincere one time
nelson mandela he just brought nelson
into this
nelson mandela was asked if he was a
saint
and he said
i'm only a saint if you consider a
sinner who keeps on trying
now while that's true the question is
are you really trying stephen
i know none of us are perfect but how
long are you gonna know you're doing
wrong
and keep doing it you know what
something that actually nobody knows is
that i grew up mormon as well all of his
excuses and pocket quotes pushed the
other cast members to speak up
i don't think that it's abnormal to have
you know different sexual desires uh
what i find wrong here is
throughout you know these past months we
saw stephen trying to
show elina the book of mormon and just
talking about church and how to do right
yes
but he's been doing the complete
opposite
it's very important to me i did grow up
in lds church you slept with some well
um okay but i'm not going out there and
saying like i am an active member of the
church and doing these things because
i'm not following the standards that the
church has set stephen represents
himself as an active member of the
church and that is what i have such a
big problem with speaking of the church
steven's ex-girlfriend vanessa who he
met at church joined the tell-all to
warn alina about his behavior
when you first met stephen what
attracted you to him initially
i was going through a bit of a faith
crisis
i i grew up lds as well
and
along came steven and he was
really nice according to her after they
were in a relationship for about three
months stephen was
fronting as you know a faithful man who
wanted to be in a monogamous
relationship steven went to russia for
two months and while she told him he
could date other girls while he was
there she asked him not to sleep with
anyone but he did and it wasn't just one
person so he comes back from russia and
i was his girlfriend but he confessed to
me that while he was in russia he had
had
sex with three girls and
of course that broke my heart i cried
steven is a player you know who he
reminds me of
coal while i was talking to these women
online i sent them pics
i'm ashamed of myself just like coltie
as larissa would say he's the player you
never expected it was a fleeting
moment of weakness uh nine fleeting
moments of weakness well over a couple
of days over how many years because the
same thing happened whether you've had
sex with three women in russia please i
i can't take the vote sean advised
vanessa to tell alina what she thinks
she should do
and vanessa didn't hesitate to tell her
to leave
like i know a divorce is so difficult
and you've made these vows to him
but i don't think he's going to change
if anything i would say he's gotten
worse
he hurt both of you i don't think he's
gonna change i think that vanessa's
right stephen you're not a freak or
anything but it's not fair to
you know have one foot in the door and
one foot out the door
that's kind of funny coming from someone
who just abandoned their husband
i guess steven wrote that one down on
his list
i didn't abandon my husband i went to
get my son surgery in the u.s anyway
back to vanessa's advice to alina
she ended up getting really emotional
after stephen revealed that he and alina
have agreed to go to a psychologist to
get him some help elena i want you to
know that it's not a bad thing
to leave him you're not giving up this
is not what you agreed to
when you moved to turkey
you were expecting a genuine
relationship with a man who was going to
take care of you and love you and put
you first
and that's not what you got well thank
you for um
taking care of me everyone
but i just already decided that i'm
gonna give another chance and that's
gonna be the last time
thank you baby
[Music]
lesson learned here
when someone says they are not ready for
marriage i'm not
at the same
level of readiness as you are believe
them
i think one of the biggest surprises
is that you two are here together all
right moving on to ariela and binyum who
you can see is in america
now we can confirm the rumors are true
binium got his k1 visa
[Applause]
and now you are living here in the u.s
yes
that's so awesome coming to join us in
studio is ari's ex leandro all right
well let's talk about ariella's
ex-husband leandro who joined the show
later on and can i just say this all
three of them looked so good ari
snatched binium one word skin
it's beautiful
and leandro those eyes
he was hiding in behind those glasses
i feel like just still [ __ ] how does she
love him so much looks aside it didn't
take long for binyam to open up about
how uncomfortable he is with ari and
leandro's close relationship and how
they talk on the phone for hours
if i was a girl best friend with ari and
talk for hours with her and giving her
advice even speaking in spanish would
that bother you no because bazaar me you
are his ex-husband yeah leandro come on
now you can't even compare that sean
then asks leandro if he realizes he's
causing problems in ari and benny's
relationship
i think that has to do more with his
insecurities than with the relationship
itself who thinks leandro should just
back off that's when everyone took a
poll on if leandro should back off and
they all pretty much agreed that yes he
should including binium i'm
very good friends with arie so if she
tells me back off then what about if i
tell you back off
what she has to tell me
she she is her own individual and she
needs to make that decision and ari
didn't tell him to back off she stayed
quiet
which says a lot the way it's looking at
some point she's gonna have to decide
especially now that binyan has his k1
visa sooner or later things work out
he's going to be her husband thank you
so much to all of you for being here and
letting us into your lives all right
season three of the other way is
officially a wrap
next week is the premiere of 90 day
fiance before the 90 days we're going to
get to know some new faces and see the
return of some familiar ones
gusman
get your energy up
this should be interesting
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]